and due to the camera three - I'm gonna
win this shot okay if it is the last
thing I do
see I'll have to deal with you're gonna
see a lot of cuteness drop it and win
and a lot of spiciness all spiking it's
awesome hot sauce it might be a little
bit more goofy because there's more kids
on the show and ice like we're gonna
have more energy and we're gonna be more
funny so you're saying you're gonna be
better than pretty much sorry and I
think it could be really cool to see
these like kids work really hard on
these dances and perform them on the
stage the audience have Dancing with the
Stars juniors are just gonna love that
there are younger kids on it and they're
just time in the time of their life
when I dance I feel confident I'm sorry
is something I'd field against what were
your first thoughts when you first met
each other
oh I was so excited the first thing this
is like beautiful eyes just like
eyelashes Tripp what did you think about
Haley
[Music]
I love the costumes I love like dressing
up and like hair and makeup and I just I
like that a lot I love all the costumes
I love the hair I love the makeup other
are the grips and glands is anybody
surprised by that
the most fun part about being on the
show is definitely getting to learn new
ballroom skills obviously because I've
never done ballroom in my life and
getting to make a bunch of amazing new
friends the most fun for me
is meeting new people and meeting like
getting better relationships with
everyone like you yeah I think having
fun than folding but you also need to
work hard try your best be brave and
just do it
why is our team going to win because we
are hard workers and we're also the
youngest and cutest couple yeah so I
can't wait to perform all the dances for
America I hope it can make you guys
proud
[Music]